e
yes uh I was at two minutes of 10 I was
waiting to see if we get our other
members but now it's 10:03 so I'm going
to convene uh this meeting of the
commission on worldwide combined
reporting for un unitary businesses
um I am told that Mr Foley will be
present but arriving a little late and I
believe that may also be true with
Senator Murphy so we have had uh seven
active members five of them are here and
I think we we should just get
going
uh so I think that uh it would be worth
taking a moment just to review exactly
comment so ah
perfect it was worth waiting the three
minutes welcome everybody okay we have a
full house all appointed members are
present so
so what I'd like this morning is to
shape our report and know what it's
going to look like uh and have an
opportunity to um
critique what each uh each other is
saying to the extent that there are
differences and that uh means that uh I
think we can openly engage in a degree
of persuasion if we're inclined and uh
see whether we move or uh attenuate any
position
so there are five documents that I've
just put in front of you um which Gen 4
has uh graciously copied for
us those include minutes of the October
2nd meeting
which um I guess nobody has read yet so
uh we might take a pause read them in a
few minutes and we could we could then
adopt them uh second there is a
memorandum dated November 1st
2023 this is a skeleton prepared by Gen
4 that shows the um the style and
framework of our report and its captions
and cover so basically all of our
commentary findings and recommendations
get plugged into this
format together with that
uh Jen has
prepared a uh
bibliography of cases resources
available online generally on the topic
and additional resources that have been
directly presented to us by our
presenters at our prior
hearings so that bibliography will be
attached and be incorporated into the
report itself those two documents
basically give you a preview of
of the
report uh then the fourth and fifth
documents uh one is uh have both come
from representative shamber so he's
captioned one rep Tom shamberg wwcr
commission report and then he's also got
another single page proponent of wwcr
from Minority Report of wwcr so I know
that
uh Tom had contemplated question whether
he would read that to us and I think
instead he's going to leave it to us to
read it but he's go he's got uh a
prepared comments he's going to make
verbally
um Mr Kennedy and Mr Foley have been
working on the pros and cons kind of the
the neutral view of uh uh What uh which
arguments lie on either side and uh when
we come to that they have something to
hand out as well
um I undertook to do uh the major uh the
majority opinion and and and pull
together the report and that's not ready
for prime time I I decided uh not to put
in front of you today what I've already
started to put together and uh to be
frank I wanted to get the sense of the
of the meeting today see whether
opinions shift see exactly what
representative shamberg is presented and
uh Mr Foley and Mr Kennedy and then
shape what I write around
that
uh so I was starting to say that uh
let's just review specifically what our
charge is HB 102 enacted in
2022 um basically
says the commission shall study the
advantages and
disadvantages where the state's economy
and revenues of replacement of the
current Waters Edge method by the
worldwide combined reporting method for
reporting and apportionment of income
under the business profits
tax it shall consult with national
experts in both methods including
experts so that that is the essence of
what we um are to do and I want to keep
us focused on exactly that I think we
can say with some
satisfaction that we have heard uh from
an excellent cross-section of economists
business associations and tax experts a
lot of what we have before us is
written if one was to take the time to
review the entirety of our record U
through the videos as well as reading
it's really a very very comprehensive
um set of views and opinions and advice
and and so there is no doubt in my mind
we've satisfied that
criteria so again the report then
advantages and
disadvantages for the state's economy
and
revenues of changing from Water's Edge
to uh combined
I've I've done quite a bit of reading
since our last meeting I told you I'd
read a lot but there was still some I
hadn't gotten to in addition to that uh
we have in the
meantime uh gotten the report from the
state of
Maine um and also Gen 4 uh found and
linked a very extensive report 96 pages
from the state of Rhode
Island and uh I'd just like to very very
quickly summarize what I got out of
those two
reports uh first of all
the proposal that was before the state
of Maine earlier this
year was whether to make combined world
reporting
optional they were not proposing as has
been proposed here to switch to that
system as a
mandatory uh requirement they were they
uh were simply asking the question would
they allow it as an
option and they concluded that for many
of the reasons we've heard that it would
be difficult to comply with difficult to
administer
difficult to audit but they also came
down quite simply on the point that
there wasn't really a good rationale for
giving the taxpayer an
option where you give the taxpayer an
option it invariably works against the
state's interest so we have the
situation where we
may understand that there will be
winners and losers and we may have no
ability to anticipate who the winners
are and who the losers are
what's the degree to which they're
winners or they losers or whether the
company that's a winner this year is a
loser next
year and they said when you go to an
optional system basically the taxpayer
gets to calculate the tax two ways and
choose the Lesser and it always comes
out against the state's interest so I
think it's it's an interesting report
it's a brief one it's seven pages if you
haven't read it uh you can get through
it pretty quickly and I think it informs
generally what the um challenges are of
the worldwide combined reporting even
though it was viewed in entirely
different context and they decided not
to go
forward Rhode Island it was a very very
different animal and uh I'll just
summarize it very quickly it's about 96
pages they are one of the states that uh
continues to use a separate entity um
system
uh which was the uh you the approach
that prevailed before approximately 1980
and which the federal government still
uses so there's some very brief
commentary in there it's not a
particularly helpful report to us let's
just say that they
also concluded that they would stick
with what they have so they did not uh
move in the direction of of unitary
so I think at at a certain point here
I'd like to
summarize uh what I've gotten uh out of
all the readings in terms of how this
has evolved in the state of New
Hampshire but I think I can hold that
and I want to just take a pause and uh
ask if anybody else wants to weit in at
this point and speak to the issue in any
fashion and a after we've done that
then I think I'll uh turn it to
representative
shamberg okay so
um representative shamberg why don't we
start with
you and uh then Mr Foley Mr Kennedy will
go to you and uh and I think after that
um I think that the volume of material
we have received is so voluminous I
don't make the assumption that everyone
has had a chance to plow through it and
so uh at the risk of being somewhat
redundant to what you may have read I
would reserve some time after that to
Hampshire representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman
uh I have presented uh as the chair has
stated uh the
uh as a proponent
of
wwcr uh a
basic
position that I think should be
recognized uh and then I if someone
didn't want to read that they could read
the bullet points okay uh and to to
simplify it a little bit for someone to
understand but what I would like to do
right now is to just make
a oral presentation
about the reasoning
for worldwide combined
reporting and uh so and I'm sorry
there's there's no time constraint as
far as I'm concerned thank you
sir and it won't it won't be that that
long
okay uh because I did type it out for
myself um the fundamental findings of
this uh worldwide combined commission
have found nothing to refute that
domestic businesses under Waters
Edge Waters Edge method are at a
disadvantage as the 1999 uh New
Hampshire Supreme Court volunteered in
the caterpillar decision they quoted we
point out the waters edge method was
adopted for the benefit of foreign
businesses so what we presently have is
a fundamental question of the rule of
law there should not be two tiers in our
tax system any more than there should be
two tiers of
Justice uh if we're going to have two
tiers in our tax system as indicated by
the
1999 Supreme Court decision new
Hampshire then I say this is uh
anti-democratic and anti-free Market uh
it can only erod
confidence in our institutions of
self-government in the New Hampshire
house Ways and Means Committee it would
be irresponsible of me and my colleagues
uh to fail in the mission to protect a
Level Playing Field when it comes to tax
policy if we are going to pick winners
and losers I believe the New Hampshire
taxpayers would find it
unconscionable that we tilt or continue
to tilt uh New Hampshire tax law The
Waters Edge tax method in favor of non
us
corporations this is the present in
equity in our current New Hampshire
business tax
system New Hampshire's only
sustainable uh source of Revenue is
taxes and taxes play a vital role in our
New Hampshire system Society for our
state our towns uh cities and counties
all New Hampshire taxpayers have a
responsibility to the New Hampshire
Society the New Hampshire Marketplace
like the rest of America's public
marketplaces provide a topnotch public
infrastructure an educated Workforce
critical public services and the rule of
all and all of these are supported one
way or another by tax dollars
every business domestic or Global here
in New Hampshire
benefits from that educated New
Hampshire Workforce and infrastructures
and all should pay their fair share to
support it we have indicators from the
tax Justice Network the fact Coalition
which is called Financial accountability
and corporate transparency and ITP
Institute Taxation and economic policy
and other reporting functions
that the US loses around $176 billion do
yearly by profit shifting with New
Hampshire missing out on an average of
$177 million in the business profits
tax this information is from public data
driven reports not fear mongering
talking points without providing
financial data there was no statistical
data from the global business Alliance
or the console on state taxation about
data showing lower BPT Revenue because
these organizations know it will result
in showing more BPT revenue for New
Hampshire when presentations were made
from the New Hampshire Society of
CPAs nothing
personal about challenges of the wwcr
that would be faced by practitioners and
the business Community about gathering
information a new le has stepped forward
the United States government under
Senate Bill s 638 which was signed into
law that now requires large
multinational companies to begin public
country bycount reporting and
operational data to the SEC not just to
the Internal Revenue
Service the required information
includes but is not limited to a list of
subsidiaries their main activity their
Revenue their profit their tax the
number of employees their stated Capital
their accumulated earnings and tangible
assets this information is needed by the
United States to improve tax enforcement
and arm the the
investors with information they need to
allocate their funds wisely this new
federal approach of country by country
will help close
loopholes because of tax transparency
and also serves to clarify
and standardize reporting
requirements the approach of the wwcr is
an accounting method that staves off tax
avoidance
strategies but this was received by the
New Hampshire Dr with a claimed neutral
position but the Dr implied that ending
Waters Edge method and going to the
worldwide combined reporting would add
additional auditing burdens due to
currency and Lang language
difficulties but current New Hampshire
Law requires companies to rationalize
currency and language just as the
federal government requires these
companies to do Under the new federal
disclosure of tax Havens and offshoring
act the Dr is the only New Hampshire
organization that can take the present
Waters Edge tax method and policy and
either show it as an impartial tax that
ignores artificial legal distinctions
among types of businesses or it can show
that foreign multinationals are a
privileged class under the waters edge
method this privilege causes domestic
companies to pay a higher effective tax
rate than their multinational
competitors when privileged
multinational corporations shift their
tax revenue profits it is the smaller
domestic companies that have to shoulder
the revenue raising burden
since the request for the slow
implementation of the single Factor
single sales Factor was ignored without
hearings back in 2019 by the New
Hampshire Senate The Honorable
Representative Patrick abramy who was
vice chair of New Hampshire Ways and
Means Committee wrote we may do
significant harm to the Financial Health
of our state when you take the single
sales Factor along with the implication
of what Waters Edge allows foreign
multinationals to do with BPT tax
revenues the state of New Hampshire
needs a law
implemented implemented which would
increase tax
transparency this is
the worldwide combined
reporting the wwcr tax policy increases
TR tax transparency and will encourage
multinational corporations to steer
clear of most questionable
practices we need to put every business
domestic and foreign on the same Level
Playing Field the state of New Hampshire
does not need two tiers in our tax
system one for foreign multinationals
and one for domestic
companies why should this commission
oppose fair tax policy reform for New
Hampshire domestic businesses when our
own New Hampshire Supreme Court has said
we point out that the Waters Edge method
was adopted for the benefit of foreign
businesses thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
shamberg are there questions for
representative
shamberg if you wait too long he'll put
his hand up I'm counting on it
representative
Hy
uh thank you um I'm reading this an
article here on uh from the tax
Foundation which questions and I just
got it this morning so um I will share
it with the committee but it questions
the ITP information because it uh for a
variety of different reasons and it also
suggests that the estimated
revenue does not take into consideration
the corporate task
portion that exists under the Water's
Edge Pro process I'm sure our uh CPA at
the end well either one of you two can
figure
out how that can be put into Layman's
English but it it looks to me like it's
a a b an imbalance in tax rate
application to General Revenue
previously Mr uh representative shamberg
has suggested that it is widening the
tax
base which may be true but it also
limits the ability of a corporation
therefore to utilize move funds shift
funds to areas that it may um be more
beneficial for the uh production of a
product that may in grow businesses for
example uh if a corporation is engaged
in harvesting hemp I'm just going to
stay away from Hightech
stuff and there's a factory in India
that has a very good processing
methodology doing on the cotton and the
British cotton industry there where they
can process this product better but it
grows better
in country a but the manufacturer of it
in country B is better and even there's
a tax difference between the two
countries why would the compant
corporation then be penalized for
shifting funds from growth to profits
from the growth and sale of that product
over to the manufacturing side that it's
located elsewhere and how does that harm
a New Hampshire business that is paying
effectively the same tax rate you
indicated in your statement that it uh
was an unequal tax burden even
though we can create as it's been
repeatedly said under our uh under our
our constitution we can create different
classes of taxable
entities I'm I I really do not
understand that can
you I will try
to Enlighten just a little
uh I I if they
are at a true arms
length apart from each other and which
means
a has
no connection with be in the
management of be's company uh true arms
length would be me and you working that
deal not
me as your unitary boss your unitary
telling you I I would like you
to make a deal with me that is
not but that's not how corporations work
well I realiz I'm sorry I sure no I
think um representative ol wants to
mic that's not how corporations work if
you've got a corporation that is
producing product a over here and
then manufactures that product or
refines that product or does something
else with that product over there it's
still the same
Corporation it and if they're not at
arms length they work together and by
working together they produce a product
that benefits the stockholders in the
corporation and it benefits the people
that buy the
product because it's not you're not
having to produce profit for each one of
the company separate you're producing a
a product that benefits that entire
entity that's manufacturing that product
and it seems to me that this uh tax
scheme now all of them are schemes
well bad said that um but Frederick
basad a French philosopher but what I'm
I'm trying to get at is why would you
penalize a corporation from doing
business I don't think we're penalizing
all we're looking for is a transparency
shifting any of this profit that the
state or tax revenues at the State of
have for a economic advantage over a
domestic company that may not have
that uh ability to uh uh uh deal with
that that
company I think when you have a unitary
unitary setup where you have
subsidiaries you as the top management
Central
core can make and ask
for cost differentials that a domestic
company if it was to deal with a company
get yes so
what
I go back to New Hampshire wants to make
sure that it is able to provide for the
people of this state through its public
Marketplace and it can't do it without
taxes
proper Revenue that should be accounted
Hampshire yes Senator
murphi thank Mr chairman
at the last meeting I laid out a few
reasons why I didn't support the idea
and I still believe all of those things
um probably the strongest reason I
couldn't support it Beyond a basic
philosophical difference is what you've
labeled as sort of the weakest or least
persuasive argument which is the going
at alone you know New Hampshire has
about
4%
of the states of the nation's population
it's a it's a minuscule amount um not 4%
.4% carry the decimal point over 0
4% um and I I
can't to me that's just a a massive
reason why we can't even consider this
seriously and at the risk of hurting my
own position I would suggest that if you
were to continue to work on this project
and it's something you've clearly been
working on for a while maybe a
contingency might be a way to go um if
10% of the country were to support it
maybe this goes away as a
reason um so you know we have a saying
legislature and I folks you've been here
a while as well never try to improve a
bad Bill
but this would at least address one of
so I think it's probably worthwhile at
the risk of stating the obvious to make
some distinctions between different
kinds of
Corporations um we have us-based
corporations we have foreign-based
corporations we have us-based
multinational corporations and
foreign-based multinational corporations
doing business in the United
States we have businesses that do no
international business but are operating
in a multiple of
states and uh those could be New
Hampshire Corporation operating in other
states it could be a corporation from
anywhere else Oklahoma doing business uh
here and there are many corporations
that are doing business in most of the
states if not all 50 that are not
necessarily operating
multinationally so at at the end of the
day the common denominator in terms of
the New Hampshire BPT is whether they
Hampshire I'm completely failing to
see that you're making a distinction
between foreign multinationals and us
multinationals so the suggestion has
discriminates amongst these types of
businesses and specifically that it
discriminates against domestic
companies but the water's edge is simply
a way of
circumscribing where we're applying the
unitary method okay so the separate
filing method historically prevailed
before more or less 1980 is
little earlier in certain States 1980 in
New
Hampshire the the separate filing method
continues to Prevail at the federal
level they've never changed it goes back
30s New Hampshire did adopt a unitary um
81 it's the the the the context of the
water's edge is not to change the fact
that we have unitary filing it's simply
to say that the businesses you that a
corporate parent may have outside the
country that don't themselves have an
Nexus are not relevant to activity in
New Hampshire and therefore not relevant
to our desire to tax
fairly so we're not
treating us-based multinationals any
fact the change of law in
1986 was motivated by almost the
opposite predicament so this is subtle
and this didn't hit me the first time I
started reading these documents but on
much closer reading it's become very
clear to me from the legislative history
of the 198 86 law change in New
Hampshire that the state of New
Hampshire urged by the Department of
Revenue and uh governor governor sununu
the uh the first governor sununu were
trying to resolve a predicament in which
the state was discriminating between
1981 and 86 and here's here's
how when New Hampshire implemented
worldwide comb B reporting in
1981 they never applied it to
foreign based
multinationals that was shocking to me
when I read
that in fact there are extensive
passages in representative Schamberg's
tax notes article that uh confirm this
very
plainly and the commissioner of the
Department of Revenue said quite plainly
out of Ways and Means Committee hearing
in the spring of
1986 that they had never received a tax
return from any foreign-based
multinational
corporation using the unitary
method so they had a conundrum they had
a
law that said New Hampshire was using
combined worldwide reporting but they
were applying it only to us-based multin
and foreign-based
multinationals were just simply skating
along ignoring that
law and the officials of the State of
New Hampshire make it plain that that
wasn't a situation where the
foreign-based multinationals were just
trying to get away with something it was
an instance where the state of New
Hampshire was
completely
incapable and
unprepared to enforce their own law and
audit Etc against the foreign-based
multinationals so they made it a plain
they plainly communicated that they
wouldn't even
try so when they came to 1986 after a
prior
Bill the governor got so directly
involved in this that he personally
testified on at least two occasions
before house and Ways and Means on that
bill
urging that we move to Waters Edge so
that the Discrimination between domestic
multinationals versus foreign
multinationals could be
ended the purpose of Water's Edge was to
make sure that the domestic
multinationals and the foreign
multinationals were in fact treated
alike now if I'm the CEO of a US
us-based
multinational I can't see any way in
which I'm disadvantaged relative to my
foreign-based multinational competitor
were treated the same I think where
there is at least
potentially a grounds for concern and
criticism it's when you come to a new
hampshire-based business that's doing
business only in the state of New
Hampshire but those businesses including
the painter we heard from aren't comp
competing by and large with with
multinationals as and it's um I think it
was Mr Kennedy who asked uh you know
what does a business that's based in New
Hampshire and operating only in New
Hampshire have to
gain from moving away from Water's Edge
and back to to the worldwide combined
reporting and as far as I can see the
answer is nothing so I think that this
this entire proposal is
predicated on a conceptual problem I'm
not going to suggest that opportunity is
not present for any
multinational regardless of whether it's
to deliberately use um transfer pricing
for the purpose of
Shifting profits to a lower tax
jurisdiction clearly that opportunity
exists
I'm not going to deny that it probably
happens to some degree or
another but the fact is the state of New
Hampshire despite what its law said from
1981 to
1986 has
never had or
enforced a worldwide combined reporting
regime and that was really surprising
and enlightening to me to read everybody
needs to know that despite what was on
the books this state has never
implemented unified worldwide combined
reporting and there are reasons for
that
so yesterday I said H why don't I go
look in my old boxes and see if I can
find and so uh here are my souvenirs
which I anybody wants to look at them
Canen but um took me three or four
minutes to find the right box and pull
out the briefs that I was on to the
United States Supreme Court in November
1983 another brief in October 83 in the
case of shell petroleum versus Graves
Graves being the executive officer of
the Franchise Tax Board State of
California raising issues that were not
actually resolved in the container case
which had been decided at the beginning
of October 83 it's very intriguing to me
I'm just speaking personally here of
course I took a deep dive into this very
thorny topic as a young associate
attorney with Wilmer Cutler and
Pickering in Washington in 1983 and that
case closed and we didn't the Supreme
Court did not Grant
serar and I moved on to other
assignments and
here I find myself curiously 40 years
later having given utterly no thought to
the topic in the intervie years and now
taking a deep dive once again and the
basic issues and merits haven't changed
the allegations the the concerns that
were
expressed in
1983 are the same and they haven't
gotten clearer and they haven't gotten
more
concrete
so who were we representing we we were
representing 20 European
countries and the notion that there was
sort of a secret bargain between uh
President Reagan and uh prime minister
Thatcher has been has been
suggested that's really not
true the president's personal memo to
the prime minister may have been a um
confidential document but uh the
European countries were very
actively
um lobbying against this litigating
against this President Reagan made it
very
clear that he would take actions to
dissuade the States from uh embracing or
continuing the unitary worldwide uh tax
SCH scheme and he did it very openly um
a commission was convened with the
Secretary of Treasury a variety of
States representatives were involved and
that's what was going on in 1984 85 as a
Prelude to the
1986 repeal in New Hampshire New
Hampshire was one of those States that
had enacted unitary worldwide
reporting and then refrained
from enforcing
it and then backed
off based on the encouragement of the
United States
government just digress for a minute to
some of the Constitutional issues which
quickly there are four constitutional
issues that I can identify that have
been raised at one time or another in
the context of this
issue the first one is
whether the states could if they
wished adopt unitary filing and more
specifically worldwide unitary
filing that has been
resolved
favorably in the two cases in 83
container and in Barkley bank and in I
think it was
94 so there's no question that a state
can do
this the second question is the the
negative uh commerce clause which is
pretty esoteric constitutional law
theory that says even when the federal
government has enacted there are still
reasons under the Commerce Clause why a
state can't take initiative to interfere
in the movement of Interstate
Commerce and uh I think that's pretty
clear that that also is not an obstacle
as long as Congress hasn't
acted and in fact Congress has not
acted but let's bear in mind that the
Commerce Clause is a limitation on
States Powers regarding interstate
commerce and has nothing to say
whatsoever about International
Commerce the third constitutional issue
is one of
preemption so could the Commerce Clause
could could the could the US Congress
under the federal Commerce Clause
law have required unitary worldwide
reporting yes they could have but they
didn't in fact they wanted to go the
opposite direction and what was in that
context what was actually going on at
the time of New Hampshire's 1986 repeal
is that there was a very strong a very
very uh intense
concern that if a bunch of States
continued to have a statute authorizing
worldwide combined reporting that would
prompt Congress to take action and
preempt in a way that would require
separate
reporting so what governor cunu stated
to the committee and what the
commissioner and the former commissioner
as well stated to the committee is that
it would be better to back down
New Hampshire and the other
states and not give Congress cause to
preempt in effect the action of New
Hampshire and the other dozen or more
States um defused that energy and
Congress in fact never did act so
preemption is always possible but was
avoided never occurred and the fourth
issue which really I've never seen
seriously uh put forward uh but it did
get raised by uh by one of our
presenters is a 14th Amendment equal
protection argument and my answer to
that is you know good luck with that one
that that is in in my personal opinion
as a former
attorney um has no legs at all um so as
as representative ol said uh
um the courts have recognized that we
can make classes and distinctions for
taxing
purposes the fact is there is no
discrimination between a us-based
multinational and a foreign-based mul
multinational any company doing business
in multiple States reports as a uni
unitary
entity within the water's edge any
Corporation whether the us-based or
foreign is allowed to exclude their
foreign
activities unless they have a
Nexus and of course that Nexus Hook is
uh is not insignificant it means that
you could have an entirely foreign
corporation that's selling into New
Hampshire and therefore has an Nexus so
the reach of our law as it
is is I think far more
extensive than the proponents of this
proposal understand and then you start
combining that with all the things that
have occurred in the in the last within
the last 35 40 years um including the
taxation of foreign um
dividends uh and the guilty and the
reduction of the federal corporate tax
rate from 35 to
21% and and and I think our report will
include a list of some of these
mitigating
developments um the temptation
to abuse transfer pricing to shift
profits out of New
Hampshire is uh has has been
substantially mitigated I won't say it's
disappeared but um I I can't see it as
being a major threat to New Hampshire's
revenues and I think the tax Foundation
article once
again I would read it um I think every
member here should take the time to read
that it just
demolishes the underlying presumptions
that allowed for EP to estimate $170
million of uh of tax that's uh that's
been left on the table so I don't know
that anybody has a methodology that
would allow us to calculate or or
estimate what that would be but it
certainly is nothing like the 170
million
um so I'm I'm going on um at some length
here
because I just think it's extremely
important to
understand number one that we do have
unitary
filing number two that there is no
distinction between us-based
multinationals and foreign based
multinationals number three that despite
what our law said from 81 to
886 we
never enforce unitary wide worldwide
combined reporting and number four the
the governor the
commissioner and the legislature in 1986
understood that by repealing worldwide
reporting and going to Water's Edge they
were solving a problem in which
differentially representative shamberg
thank you Mr chair Ju Just A a few
questions first um
tax there's no additional level within
that tax filing that says
that you're different than the other one
is that what you're saying I mean if I'm
company a domestic your company B
multinational that we're all in the same
class when we file our BPT I
mean we pay the whatever the tax rate is
we we There's no distinction between us
correct there is no distinction
okay do multi us multinationals through
is it Mr Kennedy I think you brought
about
guilty does guilty only apply to US
multinationals or Mr Foley okay it it
only applies to us shareholders of
controlled foreign Corps remember it's a
very specific subset uh and I won't go
through the whole definition again I I
think your intention is does it just hit
us businesses and or persons let's not
forget humans but yes but but it's only
taxed that tax is only applied to
us-based
multinationals not foreign based
multinationals that do business here in
this country well no not necessarily I
mean if I have what would be referred to
as a sandwich structure which is a
foreign parent with a US subsidiary that
also owns foreign
businesses then they're subject to
guilty on their subsidiaries activities
so it relates to an ownership interest
in a foreign court and you can't see
instances because I know transfer
pricing is so relevant um um where that
sandwich structure that foreign cor the
US business has no activities with them
they're a holding company per say
because they wanted to expand X Y and Z
and that's how they ended up so it's
always nuanced
but uh going back a little bit here to
the uh ability of domestic versus
foreign
multinationals
uh are foreign multinationals that have
subsidiaries here in this
state
uh are they able to use accounting
techniques that uh domestics cannot
use to reduce their uh uh operational
costs and yeah I I mean whether it
reduces or not are there related party
transactions is kind of the core of your
question um and in general yes sometimes
no right I mean I can't speak for All
Foreign inbounds um if there are related
party transactions the the US tax law
says we have to use transfer pricing in
the arms length principal Au 42 in the
RS there
under just highlight that that's
important part of our federal um
business tax practice is the arms length
um
so that adjustments can be
made correct with extensive regulations
in the
way U another question I have
is I guess it's the the
Dr concerning some of the statements
companies
are there let me let me look at this
picture does Water's Edge provision
obscure any part of this full picture
because companies are not required to
account for their operations outside the
this I don't know if we can fully answer
that question because um what the Dr has
uh has visability of is
when the taxpayers failure returns and
if complete the file New Hampshire
Returns the companying with uh the
federal returns submitted to us um and
and that's our visibility of course um
there there are the uh control for
corporations following with the 5471 on
we have visibility of that as well um so
those that's that's our scope in terms
of what we could
see I don't know if that answers the
question
so going back to Mr Chairman's
uh constitutional
questions has the state of New Hampshire
ever had a decision made on whether the
constitutional here in as the New
Hampshire Supreme Court ever decided
that or is it because of lack of someone
going forth
to I think that the
Constitutional arguments have been
Federal right so a a a argument under
the US Constitution tends to be heard in
a federal court could could have been
brought by any of the 50 states or or
taxpayers within those States I haven't
read the caterpillar case I don't know
precisely what was presented to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court in that case but
I don't think it had anything to do with
any federal constitutional issues well
uh my question is can the state of New
BPT divide and say those that are
domestic will will be
treated differently than those that are
foreign
multinationals so I I I think the answer
is that if circumstances allowed for
that kind of a case to be brought and
the distinction was truly based on the
nature of the
taxpayer as the
distinction as opposed to the nature of
the activity
that there probably would be a
constitutional problem but that's
not what has occurred in the history of
of litigation on this
subject and that's why I'm I'm I'm
trying to make it very clear that our
our law does not discriminate between
foreign-based multinationals in US based
multinationals it makes no difference
where the parent entity is or where it's
headquartered
what makes a difference is where the
activity is and so as to both those
types of
entities the activity that's subject to
the tax ends at the water's edge it
doesn't make a difference whether it's a
US multinational with operations in
Europe or a European company with
operations in the US the question is
what's the
Nexus and your text notes article um
presents an interesting uh example of a
situation ation with the state of
Delaware but any argument or concern
that transfer pricing is uh is a problem
for tax jurisdictions within the Waters
Edge within the 50 states has already
been resolved by our our state's
decision to use the unitary
method and U so everything amongst the
50 states is effectively neutralized
every
outside of the 50 states is beyond reach
regardless of where the corporation is
based so again I think uh if the
distinction was the nature of the entity
you might have a constitutional issue if
the issue is the difference in in the
nature of the activity you
don't representa
doy thank you Mr chair um just refresh
my memory a little bit here if you're
doing business in New Hampshire you need
to be registered as a New Hampshire
business that's
correct so any entity that is registered
as a New Hampshire business is taxed as
a New Hampshire
business regardless of the size or their
tentacles if you will or their
International relationships but they're
taxed on what they do
in New Hampshire be it a uh
Joe's pool room or it's no no longer
Boston bards what's it called I forget
but uh whether it's that type of an
operation or if
it's um flare for example which sells
all over the out of Nashville which
sells all over the
place um there're still taxed the same
because of what um the chair just said
regarding the type of business that
they're engaged in what they're doing is
they're selling this product from New
Hampshire and I if I'm not mistaken that
was one of the ground uh um foundations
even for the Wayfair decision and it
didn't make any difference where the
product was
manufactured but it was where it was
sold so that the activity in New
Hampshire is being taxed in New
Hampshire where the activity elsewhere
is somebody else's
problem yeah that's that's accurate of
course we have just moved away from a
three Factor um to a single sales Factor
so it's now uh under our new law a
question of you know the sales activity
that our use of the unitary filing
differs from the US from the federal
government which still operates under
separate
filing
however our limitation of the unitary
filing at the water's
edge allows for corporations filing tax
returns in New Hampshire to align what
they're reporting with what they report
to the federal government because the
water's edge coincides with the United
States the 50 states
a tax filing to the
IRS is comprehensive of all activity
within the 50
states New Hampshire's use of unitary
filing but limited to the waterers Edge
coincides with what the federal
government is looking
at so to go back to Senator Murphy's
comments I think one of the greatest
flaws in this concept accept this
proposal is that it basically asks the
state of New Hampshire with 34% of the
national
population to fight a battle that none
of the other 49 states is willing to
fight and the federal government is not
fight to adopt it means we would take so
seriously the notion that transfer
pricing is being abused that we're
motivated to require taxpayers to report
to New
Hampshire what the IRS doesn't re
require them to
report that monumentally changes the
task for the tasks payer to um conform
and and to file it monumentally
changes the um the challenge for the
Dr to monitor to audit and
enforce so we would
lose a lot of the benefit that we
currently enjoy in New Hampshire where
the tax return filed by a company with
the IRS is the starting point for the
Hampshire it's it's actually the more
you think about it it would be a pretty
own
well Mr chairman yes representative
shamber I uh go back to
a statement that we tax only the
activity that's here what we
tax is upon the reported
profits that they earn not the
activity and if you're
able to
reduce
your uh reported profits by some methods
class we start to see an unlevel field
starting to develop here or has already
been there um transparency is very
important
and uh as I stated with the Senate Bill
638 on the reporting of country by
country that transparency is now
starting to dissolve a little bit and I
think as we go along we're going to see
more and more information come
out about
how companies
operate uh in what they're reporting the
data you cannot get from the uh internal
Revenue Service but you can get it from
the SEC and I think there'll be some
comparisons of what is being reported to
the federal government and what is
reported here uh in New Hampshire I'd
like to bring up one other point can I
just specifically on that one all right
no no specifically on that one yes
if if s 638 which you have cited I don't
know what the statute number is
um if that's just been implemented by
the US Congress for the purpose of
information gathering and Analysis it's
going to take them a number of years to
get a track record that they can
actually work with and
analyze doesn't it behoove the state of
New Hampshire to let the federal
government explore that very very
intricate topic and uh wait to see what
they find out and what they decide to do
well it would behoove us but there are
certain legislative functions that occur
in this state that when we asked slow
down let us do some research like single
sales Factor it was just
ignored uh this Ways and Means Committee
did ask for that slowdown approach and
it was ignored so uh I I I didn't have
the privilege of being in the
legislature at the time but I imagine I
would have been right there with you on
that
point uh the one thing I'd like to just
bring up before we go any further um
even though something has been a law a
tax policy for
30 s years I got my math
right 202 37
years the case of Smith versus the
Dr uh had to do with a law that was in
effect for 70 years on interstate
commerce and it was found that that law
that the state of New Hampshire had
was counter to what interstate commerce
was and it had to do with the gentleman
being taxed
differently in the state of New
Hampshire
versus where he was filing certain
paperwork and I'm just trying to just
sort of say just because something has
been there for a period of time does not
mean that that it couldn't
become an issue for this state I would
hate to see us the money that the person
received was
undisclosed it was in the the millions
but it was undisclosed I would hate to
see us step to some
place and
say we are not to be worried about this
I think we should be a little bit
concerned about the distinctions that we
have applied to
our BPT class of domestics and
multinationals foreign multinationals
out here that they are being treated
differently within the BPT class not
that they're paying the same tax rate
to reduce its tax liability to this
not
so I I would agree that the mere passage
of time alone is no reason to revisit an
issue that was wrongly decided or um you
know the circumstances have
changed
and my argument that we not go forward
with this proposal has nothing to do
with the fact that it's been 36 years
but if you go back and
you revisit and understand what motive
ated the law in 81 and what motivated
86 you're going to find that the reasons
still stand
today and the state was resolving a
problem that we would be stepping back
to
okay this is this this is the kind of
cqu I was hoping for I mean you know
this this is a real debate um so before
we go on to uh Mr Foley Mr Kennedy is
there anything further does anybody want
to ask further questions of
Representative
shamberg he'll wait till we're in
committee well much of it will be
addressed in the final
report so I'm going to turn this over to
our two resident uh CPA
experts um so happily I think our report
will be largely anticlimactic because
pretty much everything within our
neutral report has already been
discussed uh you may recall uh at our
last meeting I had asked if we could
kind of go through the bullet points of
all of the issues that we discussed and
our report largely just took those
bullet points and added some level of
narrative to them um uh I'll pass this
out now and then I think I only need to
briefly touch base on a couple of things
because most everything in this is
largely what has been discussed already
or presented here at this meeting and I
so so as uh Mr Foley is passing these
out I I'll just hit on the the overall
organization it is largely again an
expansion of the bullet points that we
uh had discussed at the end of last
meeting um and it's organized generally
as follow uh first section is just
generally accepted
considerations um the second section is
potentially mitigating factors which the
chair had asked us to incorporate which
he had already uh mentioned and then uh
the third item is just outlining the uh
items that both support and are against
uh moving to worldwide reporting uh
again pretty much all of these have been
discussed uh and or and or expanded on
um in terms of the generally accepted
considerations uh again that
constitutionality moving to worldwide
reporting should be allowed um transfer
pricing
exists um uh however the um extent uh to
which transfer pricing um may move uh
profits out of New Hampshire is not
completely known uh New Hampshire taxes
foreign income already to some degree
including uh by the receipt of foreign
dividends and by um other um uh
anti-avoidance Provisions in the IRS
code including subp partf income and
guilty
income uh transfer pricing May create an
uneven playing field or inequity between
companies that have or do not have
uh foreign related entities um and that
currently because of numerous factors um
there's simply not a lot of information
to
quantify um uh how Revenue may be being
or profit may be being shifted out um
partly just limitations that exist for
the Dr and also partly because um the
guilty uh taxation is fairly new uh to
New Hampshire the mitigating factors uh
were discussed which is that there have
been uh various uh changes in uh since
2017 with the tax cut and jobs act
including guilty the repatriation Act
and the reduced corporate tax rate which
may mitigate some of the factors with
the transf potential transfer pricing
issue and in terms of items of support
and against again it's been largely
expanded on um the most notable item of
support is the theory that um this would
level the playing field for entities
that uh are only domestic and those that
have foreign related uh entities and
against um would be that New Hampshire
would be an outliner relative to moving
to worldwide reporting um what wasn't
mentioned and um uh was this um
potential and the word that was
presented was retaliation I don't quite
remember who the presenter was of
foreign companies uh foreign countries
if we move to worldwide
reporting um um the and then of course
the increase in administration and
compliance burden for the New Hampshire
Dr for tax payers and businesses and for
tax
practitioners um and lastly um which was
not mentioned um that I can recall in
this today's meeting is that there may
be alternatives to address uh the
transfer pricing issue um whereas um um
New Hampshire does tax guilty but it's
only at 50%
U potentially there are other means that
could be looked at relative to instead
of moving to worldwide reporting but to
address the uh transfer pricing
potential transfer pricing issue so
again rather anti-climatic at this point
um but um I think I'll next time I'll
ask to start and uh then then we've set
the foundation so uh so again I don't
know if there's anything that would have
been very wise chairman only
hadling so um uh so that that largely is
it uh I expect um uh Mr F and I will
expand on the narrative as this is
mostly in bullet form but uh again this
is largely intended just to outline and
to add some narrative to the discussions
we've all had both for and
against sorry Matt do you have anything
to
add well thank you very much
I what's particularly helpful about this
is that it's designed to sort of harvest
the arguments and catalog the arguments
on both sides and not to deny the
premise of the um
Advocates uh so I think that uh you know
we find ourselves in a situation where
we do understand how transfer pricing
can be used uh we understand that it may
have consequences and it may be abused
even though it's a perfectly normal and
absolutely
necessary uh technique between
Affiliated
entities we have no way of quantifying
uncertainty representative
Val you used a term there and necessary
practice and I I had failed to include
that in my comments but yes uh we
probably need to elaborate on the fact
that it is a NE it is necessary to take
monies from here to give it to there so
you can get this so you can get that so
that you can get your product done and
get it to Sales get it to Market yes yes
I I I think that's probably worth
stating um transfer pricing should not
be understood to be inherently
negative transfer pricing is a necessary
way of sharing expenses across
Affiliated entities where an investment
is made in one entity that's then
realized in another so the question is
how would we ever set up a regime that
um that discerns it and in fact I think
it's a very interesting point that the
unitary worldwide reporting actually
doesn't make any effort to identify
where the abuses use of transfer pricing
is it's it's if we adopted this scheme
it doesn't Aid Us in identifying or
isolating or correcting it's just a very
broad crude way of sort of saying well
if we all just pull it back together
again uh then more or less everything
will come out in the
wash treating the issue in that way
should be understood as is an
acknowledgment that we have no way of
identifying and isolating and correcting
specific
abuses and I think that
um again uh the tax Foundation article I
just think is so important to read
Because what it illustrates is that we
have to use certain
devices to get our arms around something
that's inherently unknown and you know
even with the audit uh powers that the
state has we have a limited ability to
get so far inside the books of a
taxpayer uh you know to know that they
have been actually totally compliant on
a transactions by transactions basis so
we use a series of devices and U unitary
reporting coupled with formulary
allocation is just that it's a device
and the question of uh single sales
Factor versus the three factor and uh
and and the various other questions that
come up are all about how we shape that
device at the end of the
day even if this was
implemented what we're talking about is
instructing the corporations to make a
different mathematical
calculation and it's a calculation in
which the base of taxable activity gets
expanded potentially drastically so that
the denominator of the math equation
becomes vastly
larger but the calculation still has to
assign a certain
percentage to their activity with a New
Hampshire Nexus and the result is that
the
numerator becomes correspondingly
watered down to the point where they're
making a calculation theoretically on
you know worldwide income where only an
infantes little percentage of it is
subcribed to New Hampshire um I'm not
sure we really get anywhere and I think
that we've we've read plenty of examples
where we can see that uh corporations
some corporations will be winners some
corporations will be losers and I think
that representative Al's uh Shipyard
examples were good illustrations of how
that can change from year to year and
and affiliate to
affiliate why do we want to make the
determination of New Hampshire's
business tax depend on the vicissitudes
of profit and loss in foreign places I
don't see that it makes things better I
worse if I may uh of course you may I
can see why you spoke so so well in
front of the US Supreme Court all right
oh believe me I didn't have the oral
argument oh all right all right
uh my
background and my personal makeup is
that when
I first let me say this of all our tax
policies of all our taxes we have there
are people that don't like tax
rates or like taxes but we
we can argue those points but but when I
distinctly different in in how it
approaches that that class of
individuals the class of
taxpayers uh I will I will stand up I I
just and say this is not right and
domestic businesses companies in this
state are treated differently than those
that have the capability of using
accounting methods that
uh our locals can't use
and I hope
that individuals and taxpayers
understand we encourage we want business
here but we want to treat everybody
equally because if you don't treat
everybody equally and someone starts
getting a
benefit there is going to be others on
the other side go wait a minute what's
going on here and our reputation as a
state becomes affected so I'm just
letting you know where I'm coming from
on this it's nothing personal against
any business it is let's have a Level
Playing Field thank you um you're you're
illustrating
a
challenge um that we're going to face in
writing this
report and and that is that
um I fundamentally disagree that our law
treats different classes of taxpayers
differently it is inherently true that a
company operating entirely within New
Hampshire doesn't have Affiliates in
other states let alone in other
countries it's inherently true that a
business that doesn't have Affiliates is
not in a position to use transfer
pricing that has that is not a product
of our law that's a product of their
circumstances in organization our law is
neutral I it's a very important point
and and as I say I'm I'm going to be
taking pains to try to explain expl that
in the
Valerie covered the base
well yeah and there still hasn't been a
clear definition as to how they're SE
treated differently just because one has
as you just indicated is a larger entity
having an ability it's grown it has now
for example there a law firm in
Manchester that was man that was New
Hampshire only now has got an office in
Brazil and it's got an office in
London they they grow businesses grow
and now they can take advantage of a
bunch of other
activities merely because of the size of
their operation even though the same
basic laws within New Hampshire apply
period thank you for that I yeah it's an
interesting nothing static um
corporations reorganize merge uh grow
open up new units it's very hard to say
how a particular taxpayer that's
affected in a certain way today might be
affected in 10
years I still say that it's giving a tax
advantage
to a group in a
class has nothing to do with how they go
about their operation or their business
it is still a tax advantage let me POS a
question oh
taxpayer makes a major capital
investment and they then Avail
themselves of the allowances for
depreciation and they thereby gain a tax
advantage by being able to offset some
of their income with their annual
depreciation allowance whether we're
talking about threee fiveyear equipment
40-year commercial real estate
isn't that really analogous to what
of if the other
companies can do the same
thing in approaching how
they invest or take advantage of their
uh
depreciations uh I would say yes
but I don't see domestics being able to
take advantage the same advantage that
foreign multinationals or can take when
it comes
to the
reporting of their business profits tax
that they have devices and uh uh
accounting that that can't be used by
the domestic companies so certain
businesses
um are inherently Capital intensive
right um let's say a ski area is
particularly Capital intensive because
it has the fixed initial investment of
purchasing its side of the mountain has
to have a chunk of real estate it's
going to depreciate it uh or a company
That's Heavy in u u manufacturing
equipment uh may have leased facilities
but still may have major Capital
expenses in the heavy
machinery it's just a question of using
the tax laws for the circumstances of
that particular tax Filer and um I I I I
simply fail to see how any company in
New Hampshire couldn't start doing
business in another state I can't see
how any business in New Hampshire could
not uh organize an Affiliated corporate
entity or have subsidiaries all of these
choices are available it's a question of
the needs of the
company but when they incorporate like
that in other states using a subsidiary
they still under Water's Edge there are
certain restrictions that they have that
foreign
multinationals do not have in how they
file and how they use
uh the tax system as we as we developed
it so I think I'm I'm struggling to get
you to see a different
delineation um that's why my report's
going to be different than yours well
um the water's edge applies
to the unitary requirement limited by
the water's edge applies to any company
whether they're foreign or domestic that
does businesses in more than one
the limitation of the wat's edge applies
equally to any business that's doing
business in the United States or abroad
and it's not limited to foreign
multinationals it's any
multinational so the distinctions you're
valid I have to think about that we're
all going to
okay this is going to be a very tough
report to write that's why I began by
apologizing for not having a draft in
front of you
today um what more would we like to
accomplish this
morning
and do we believe we need to meet again
I'm thinking probably yes but I'm
theoretically we could wrap up our
business uh you know uh
virtually but uh we have a tight
timeline it's November
1st I've personally held open the next
two Mondays just in case I would like to
think that if we meet again we can
probably have drafts in front of us and
wrap it up in one meeting but having
23d I will not be in state on the 23rd
okay 30th is
neither either oh either okay excellent
um if we have drafts circulated that we
can work on and meet on Monday
morning October 30th 10: a.m. here we
would then have uh two days to the close
of business on Wednesday the 1st to file
our report can we make that work I think
the real onuses on on me I think
representative shamberg you've you've
done good work in putting your advocacy
piece in and I probably will send a
revised report now sure absolutely feel
free okay and uh Mr Kennedy Mr fo you're
going to flesh your section out a little
bit more and we may want to go back and
forth a little bit in terms of seeing
how that folds into the the bigger
report yeah I I had presumed that our
report would be mostly to the committee
and not
be presented outside of the committee
but incorporated into the final report I
presume that's still a
plan yes yes what you're doing is
helping towards the draft of the
commission's
report and as you've seen from the uh
template that Gen 4 prepared for us
um our report will be transmitted to the
speaker the president of the Senate
House and Senate clerks the governor and
the state librarian under a cover Memo
from me uh and we'll come jointly from
us so I'm clear on the date we talk
Monday the 30th or Tuesday the 31st
Monday the 30th all right I I do have a
conflict at that time but it may be the
only time is there a different hour um
it's large in all day
events May I make a suggestion yes the
23rd was good for the rest of you except
me correct and you're going to be
putting yours together why not meet on
the
23rd if you
wish and then on the 30th we'll have my
then need
yes everyone needs to be here I think
six is a
call think we have 12 MERS so
okay all right so I am advised
fortunately I have a good
advisor that uh we need to have all
seven of us present in order to have a
quorum to conduct business so we it is
important that we pick a day and a time
everybody
seven let me ask let me ask this Jen
would we need all seven here just for
the work
session without a decision being made
and then the 30th come back in and have
news the statute that authorizes Us in
section four includes this sentence six
members of the commission shall
okay
uh
well so um what do we think about
representative Schamberg's idea that we
get together next Monday even though he
won't be able to be with us I think it's
a good
idea I think it would be a good idea for
word smithing and the incorporation of
the uh uh CPA uh section so that they
know exactly how what going going to fit
in and then we can just in include uh on
the the next Monday uh their section we
can have some more words Smith in
between the two of us and include uh
representative sham Berg's uh um counter
proposal and B I think that's that's
valuable it gives us nine days to then
pull it together it also let's be frank
fire you've turned the heat on in your
house
already okay so uh unless there's
anything further that anybody would like
to add Monday the 23rd Monday the 23rd
10:00 a.m. here and Jen we can work with
Karen to get that noticed would that be
called a work
session okay a regular commission a
regular commission meeting what about
the 30th or the 31st for the
final Kevin can't make it well let's
hold the 30th uh we might even want to
notice it and then cancel it if we don't
need
it so the next two Monday mornings at
10:
adjourned